the coffins of the Innocents
most children
killed as they slept
body after body has arrived here and
unfathomable procession of grief so many
lives ended just as they've begun
this the day their parents worlds fell
apart foreign
an excruciating aftermath
of an attack on a daycare center in
northeastern Thailand
authorities identified the attacker as
pannier kamrap a former police officer
who they say was fired in June after
being caught with amphetamines
armed with a pistol and a knife he
killed dozens of children aged between
two and four
many were taking a nap killed alongside
their teachers
police say he then went home and killed
his wife and child before killing
himself
Joy is waiting to see her son sumai he's
in intensive care at Nong bua lampu
Hospital
the three-year-old is still unconscious
he was stabbed and shot in the head
twice
he is one of the very few survivors and
his mother saw the bloodshed
my heart was broken she told me she says
She fainted when she saw all the bodies
on the ground her husband desperately
searched for her son and then they
suddenly saw Rescuers carrying him to
the ambulance
what is your son like
he's very Lively and very talkative she
says this morning he begged me not to go
to school but I forced him
it is a heartbreaking detail in a
community
overwhelmed by many more
outside the hospital the public health
Minister who's been at bedsides trying
to support the many bereaved families
definitely it's gonna it is the worst
that the worst situation that ever
happened in Thailand
horrible what was that feeling like
inside the hospital
depressed
I saw
the young children
three or four years of age
were brutally beaten
mass shootings in Thailand are rare
this level of loss unprecedented and
this only the first few moments of a
very traumatic road ahead
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Thailand